I want to get a little bit personal with
you because you and Chloe Bennet who is
your co-star in this movie did date for
a little bit now that some time has
passed does this movie sort of bring up
any movie because it reminds you of that
time um no no it doesn't you know it's a
good question and and it's it's an
inevitable thought obviously yeah cuz
Chloe and I got close on set and had a
relationship thereafter and that girl
changed my life like I have so much love
for her I have so much love for Chloe
and I'm I'm so blessed that I got to do
that movie and spend spend time with her
and and reap the benefits of just being
in her presence but we're out we are on
good terms amicable platonic friendly
and we both just appreciate each other
as humans so no no no old old like
romantic feelings whatever but it was a
very um you know it's nostalgic watching
back this this time in my life where I
was going through so many changes both
both personally and publicly and she
played a monumental role in that and so
yeah yeah well I mean he said she
changed your life those are some big
that's a bold statement how how did she
change your life she's I I never had a
mentor or someone to point me in the
right direction when I was making bad
decisions which at that time my life was
a lot
and she in many ways became a light for
me in a time where I did not have one
and and III moved forward I carry on
today in my life with values that she's
instilled in me that I I wouldn't gotten
from anywhere else or have it thus far
and the edge like she's just she's the
the the principles in way in the way she
lives her life in the way she thinks
about people and her empathetic nature
was was contagious to me in many ways
like you learned you learn from the
people you hang out with be plenty of
time with and she's definitely one of
the most impactful people that I've ever
had the pleasure of coming across in her
life that's like one of the nicest
things that anybody's ever said about
anybody yeah you know what the girls a
gem she she she deserves it yeah I'm
glad you guys are on good terms though
because we didn't really know what was
going on for a while and you never
really confirmed you were dating and so
it's nice to to finally hear that there
was a light at the end of that there was
there was and I'm glad to say that yeah
[Music]